A bit related perhaps to the last answer you gave.
Do you think English teachers will ever become obsolete?
That's a really, really fascinating question, I think that there'll be...
...lots of different models in the future. I think that simulations, for instance, will grow.
And so there will be, along with real world teachers, there'll probably be things like,...
...a teaching avatar or something which has a degree of knowledge.
But, I don't think, first of all, the artificial intelligence is going to be so developed that...
...a language teacher will completely disappear.
I think there'll be lots of interesting things bent towards going along together.
And so you could have a situation for instance where, person A and person B speak to each other...
...but each sentence they're saying is being translated through something else.
And so they might not necessarily be a teacher in that particular interchange.
And all of those things we can't really predict or see at the moment. But they will change things.
So I don't see that the teacher will become obsolete.
I think it will be much more, the teacher will be one of the key elements...
...running through language teaching and learning.
Along with lots of other elements as well.